e aí
e hoje é dia nove de julho - 115º dias
de isolamento social e não eu não estou
esgotada parece estranho ver uma médica
de uti convide em plena pandemia dizer
que não está esgotada eu já estive mas
hoje eu queria compartilhar o porquê do
não está mais votada aquele filme de
terror que a gente viveu lá no início
tentando absorver toda mudança dentro e
fora da nossa rotina no hospital
tentando adivinhar quanto tempo eu
passaria sem ver a minha família e
transformando o almoço na copa da outra
e convide no ritual de banho de água
quando a marmita ou até mesmo no copo
descartável quando fazia 24 horas era
gelo nariz para aliviar a dor da máscara
depois de um banho lavando o cabelo mais
vezes com habitual se sentindo com a
pele toda ressecada sem tomar água sem a
mínima energia
me dá
olá tudo isso no início parecia tanto
sacrifício ali talvez eu estivesse
esgotada mas hoje não lá no início
apesar do medo da morte a sua
banalização se tornou comum e talvez
para mim foi um mais difícil de absorver
nessa pandemia aí visibilização da morte
a partir de quando ela foi para
periferia outro grupo de risco tornou os
números rotineiros desfez a identidade
humana de cada morte e transformou o
ensino placar diário ninguém da sua
família né mesmo os caixões vazios o ser
chamada de assassina por familiares
durante uma notícia de óbito ou quanto
você ganha para atestar um óbito para o
convívio
aí como doí ouvir isso como isso tudo me
incomodou como esse barulho me incomodou
mas hoje eu repito eu não estou esgotada
hoje eu prefiro me lembrar do danilo do
seu francisco danilo um rapaz de 32 anos
filho do seu francisco e acabava de
perder o pai o quinto familiar que ele
pedia para convide o danilo nem imagina
mas ele mudou a minha vida dá notícia de
óbito sem dúvida se tornou nas partes
mais difíceis para mim nessa pandemia
aquela sensação de sair de casa para
testar o hábito dia todo de uma mesma
doença
e não poder abraçar um familiar que
acaba de perder um parente tem medo até
de oferecer um copo de água e contaminar
mais um familiar com copo de hospital
não sabia qual seria a reação da família
diante de uma noite uma doença tão
desacreditada no início tudo era muito
novo muita ansiedade mas o danilo ele
mudou minha forma de enxergar essa
pandemia
e depois da notícia de óbito do seu pai
o danilo teve um surto psiquiátrico ele
gritava viram desgraçado e acabou
quebrando a janela do hospital ele
chorava enxugava as lágrimas assim como
todos os outros familiares e eu ali
novamente precisava dizer danilo eu sei
que está difícil eu sei que no momento
mas por favor se puder evitar tocar nos
olhos bem se as lágrimas escorrerem o
hospital tá todo contaminado o danilo me
prometeu que ia tentar e continua me
contando a história dos outros
familiares que adoeceram já mais calmo o
danilo me pediu desculpa pelo surto e me
agradeceu ele me disse doutora
e graças a deus o meu pai morreu nas
mãos de alguém como a senhora foi deus
que colocou tanto carinho próximo a ele
no final da vida e aí tem começou a
chorar tentando segurar fui eu eu
agradeci me despedir e quando já tava
voltando para você ir com vidro e sem
perceber acabei levando minhas mãos aos
olhos para enxugar uma lágrima e aí vem
o danilo correndo no corredor e me
gritando doutora por favor não toca as
mãos nos olhos se cuida
e o danilo nem sonha com a importância
dessa frase na minha vida
e eu tinha acabado de avisar para o
danilo que eu e minha equipe não tinham
sido capazes de devolver o seu pai de
volta para sua família eu tinha acabado
de avisar para o danilo que ele pediu
quinto familiar para uma mesma doença e
o danilo não são não teve raiva de mim o
daniel nem agradeceu o danilo quis
cuidar de mim
e o danilo sempre foi e sempre será a
maioria e é esse o barulho que a gente
deve ouvir nesse mesmo dia pela manhã
nesse mesmo plantão eu havia sido
chamada de assassina por uma mãe que
acabava de perder a filha também para o
convide eu não julgo cada um tem uma
resposta psicológica ao trauma o
desastre mas ser chamada de assassina
estão da minha própria vida para tentar
salvar dos outros como assim eu passei a
manhã toda daquele plantão pensando
nisso mas no final da tarde depois o
danilo eu realmente percebi qual o
barulho eu queria ouvir
e a dona luzia foi uma outra paciente
que mudou fez uma grande transformação
na minha vida 68 anos hipertensa
diabética obesa ela realmente precisou
se entubada
e eu expliquei o procedimento jurei que
ela não sentiria dor e ela me pediu para
fazer uma vídeo chamada com a filha
antes de itu bala a filha atendeu e aos
prontos para saber que a mãe seria
entubada e esse ou aquele discurso que
se tornou uma tortura para toda a equipe
de saúde que assiste essas vídeo
chamadas aquele discurso conteúdo de
despedida que toda a família tenta
segurar e disfarçar o choro mas não
consegue disfarçar o teu olho despedida
nesse tipo de ligação mas dona luzia não
permitiu a dona luzia deu um tapa na
minha cara de toda equipe de saúde que
assistir a videochamada
e antes que a filha eo marido continuar
sendo aquele discurso pesado a dona
luzia disse filha parou parou que a
doutora não tá com tempo para mim tu bar
não eu só liguei porque eu preciso fazer
um pedido na verdade é uma ordem eu
quero
e aí
o que você compra o vestido para mim
alta eu nunca imaginei o visto antes de
muito bastão enquanto separava o
material a dona luzia me disse doutora
promete para mim que eu vou ver minha
filha e só deus sabe como dói quando a
gente promete não consegue cumprir eu
prometi
e com todo o material separado a dona
luzia me disse doutora pode vir tomar eu
amo a minha vida eu vou viver a dona
luzia sabia ela ia ver a filha ela
queria viver e ela viveu a dona luzia só
que ele um vestido para alta hospitalar
dona luzia sabe o valor da vida quantos
só se dão conta desse valor à vida e do
respeito à vida no leito de uti
e talvez o cartão próximo da vida e da
morte tô indo nós área da saúde por um
lado depressivos por outro amantes da
vida e foi isso que essa pandemia me
tornou hoje eu dou muito valor à minha
vida já passou da hora de se deslocar
para o próximo chega de nos imunizar mas
a sensibilidade chega de banalizar
sofrimento chega de fadiga compaixão era
isso que eu pensava lá atrás a 115 dias
hoje depois o danilo da dona luzia e de
tanto outros pacientes e familiares eu
percebi que sim dá para acreditar na
humanidade e sim vai passar
ah tá todo mundo cansado não é para ser
diferente é uma pandemia mas fiquem pode
se lembra do privilégio que é poder
estar em casa nesse momento tão delicado
para a sociedade que quem não pode estar
em casa se lembra do privilégio que é
poder sair se for com saúde comida de
proteção para continuar lutando para
colocar comida na mesa e não lutando
pela sobrevivência no leito de uti que
quem tá nesse exato momento no leito de
uti se lembra do privilégio que ele está
numa fila de uti que aqueles que estão
ansioso por encontrar os familiares se
lembra do privilégio que ter uma família
completa e não afetada pelo convívio
o que a gente sai para postar na
gratidão por estarmos vivos depois de
120 dias de uma pandemia mundial mais
próximos do fim do que antes aquele todo
mundo vai pegar não precisa ser verdade
eu ainda não me contaminei talvez por
sorte genética imunidade cruzada mas por
excesso de cuidados
e talvez eu esteja contaminada nesse
exato momento apesar de tantos testes
negativos mas talvez eu saio dessa
pandemia mesmo com uma médica que a tua
e até 43 convide sem me contaminar 83
mil profissionais de saúde já desceram
no brasil o meu maior respeito e
sentimentos
olá a todos os colegas que a gente
perdeu nessa batalha
é mas já parou para pensar quais
profissionais de saúde altamente postos
ainda não se contaminaram quantos
realmente não irão se contaminar será
que a gente precisa realmente acreditar
que todo mundo precisa se contaminar e
que para nós vai ser apenas uma gripe
e eu me lembro de um dia
e eu não sei quando isso vai acabar
ninguém tem essa resposta a gente segue
contando os dias sem saber quando chega
ao fim mas sabendo ou menos que a gente
está mais próximo do que antes se
e no início eu via tudo isso como
sacrifício hoje eu só consigo pensar
como seria na idade média a gente tá
vivendo uma pandemia com uma promessa de
vacina em tempo sem precedentes na
história da humanidade nada certo a
gente não tem nada concluído mas a gente
tem a ciência a ciência que nos ensinou
a cuidar melhor desses pacientes a
ciência que segue buscando a cura e
reduzindo a mortalidade sim a gente tem
a ciência uma ciência que se pede um
tempo que nos promete uma vacina e te
pede por favor lava a mão usa máscara e
se puder fica em casa isso tudo vai
passar vai passar é a única certeza e é
unânime já está passando será que vale
mesmo a pena a gente chutar o balde
depois de 115 dias de isolamento será
que vale mesmo a pena a gente chutar o
balde com uma
é mais promissoras em pleno século 21
sendo testadas no brasil
é sim tá todo mundo esgotado eu me
lembro de um dia que eu quase não lavei
um talher que encostou na mesa da copa
da uti com vigília
e o álcool tava longe e não tinha
detergente na pia eu tava cansada
daquele lava lava mas eu me lembrei da
minha mãe e eu me lembrei de alguns
pacientes eu pensei eu quero ver a minha
mãe de novo
ou será que a minha vida vale a preguiça
de passar o com um garfo será que ver o
meu pai a minha mãe de novo não vale
qualquer esforço aí que esforço é esse
e lava a mão usar uma máscara sim tá
todo mundo cansado eu também quase não
lavei o garfo nesse dia eu também quase
não usei a máscara n95 quando eu não
tava no setor do convide no hospital
talvez esse fosse o meu chutar o balde
é mas a dona luzia ele me ensinou que eu
também quero viver e que eu não posso
chamar de sacrifício lá nas mãos quando
muitos não têm acesso algo sabão eu
quero viver e não serão mais seis meses
um ano de auto cuidado que vão me pedir
isso
e eu posso me contaminar eu posso
adoecer mas eu vou me cuidar que todo
mundo que tá agora esgotado
emocionalmente ou financeiramente se
lembre que lavar as mãos usar máscara e
não levar mal rosto pode te levar vivo
até a cura uma vacina
o que confiar na ciência e acreditar em
dias melhores nesse momento é questão de
sobrevivência e que acreditem para
alguns realmente pode ser uma gripe para
outros pode ser a morte mas para você
pode ser apenas uma lembrança de um
período difícil de isolamento social com
medidas de higiene aguardando a curva
vacina eu repito nem todos precisam se
contaminar escolha um viver e acreditem
vai passar obrigada e